It was almost two years later
when I realized what this person should be called.
I was speaking at the University of Michigan
to the MBA candidates,
talking about the lessons that I had learned
after my three short years on Wall Street,
and then it came to me.
I said, "Oh, this person that is carrying your interest,
or as I like to say, carrying your paper into the room,
this person who is spending
their valuable political and social capital on you,
this person who is going to pound the table on your behalf,
this is a sponsor.
This is a sponsor."
And then I said to myself,
"Well, how do you get a sponsor?
And frankly, why do you need one?"
Well, you need a sponsor, frankly,
because as you can see,
there's not one evaluative process that I can think of,
whether it's in academia, health care, financial services,
not one that does not have a human element.
So that means it has that measure of subjectivity.
There is a measure of subjectivity in who is presenting your case.
There is a measure of subjectivity
in what they say
and how they interpret any objective data that you might have.
There is a measure of subjectivity in how they say what they're going to say
to influence the outcome.
So therefore, you need to make sure that that person who is speaking,
that sponsor,
has your best interests at heart
and has the power to get it, whatever it is for you,
to get it done behind closed doors.
Now, I'm asked all the time,
"How do you get one?"
Well, frankly, nirvana is when someone sees you in an environment
and decides, "I'm going to make it happen for you.
I'm going to make sure that you are successful."
But for many of us in this room, we know it doesn't really happen that way.
So let me introduce this concept of currency
and talk to you about how it impacts your ability to get a sponsor.
There are two types of currency in any environment:
performance currency and relationship currency.
And performance currency is the currency that is generated
by your delivering that which was asked of you
and a little bit extra.
Every time you deliver upon an assignment above people's expectations,
you generate performance currency.
It works exactly like the stock market.
Any time a company says to the street
that they will deliver 25 cents a share
and that company delivers 40 cents a share,
that stock goes up, and so will yours.
Performance currency is valuable for three reasons.
Number one, it will get you noticed.
It will create a reputation for you.
Number two, it will also get you paid and promoted
very early on in your career
and very early on in any environment.
And number three, it may attract a sponsor.
Why? Because strong performance currency
raises your level of visibility in the environment, as I said earlier,
such that a sponsor may be attracted to you.
Why? Because everybody loves a star.
But if you find yourself in a situation
where you don't have a sponsor,
here's the good news.
Remember that you can exercise your power and ask for one.
But here's where the other currency is now most important.
That is the relationship currency,
and relationship currency is the currency that is generated
by the investments that you make in the people in your environment,
the investments that you make in the people in your environment.
You cannot ask someone to use their hard-earned
personal influential currency on your behalf
if you've never had any interaction with them.
It is not going to happen.
So it is important that you invest the time to connect, to engage
and to get to know the people that are in your environment,
and more importantly to give them the opportunity to know you.
Because once they know you,
there's a higher probability that when you approach them
to ask them to be your sponsor,
they will in fact answer in the affirmative.
Now, if you're with me and you agree that you have to have a sponsor,
let's talk about how you identify a sponsor.
Well, if you're looking for a sponsor,
they need to have three primary characteristics.
Number one, they need to have a seat at the decision-making table,
they need to have exposure to your work
in order to have credibility behind closed doors,
and they need to have some juice,
or let me say it differently, they'd better have some power.
It's really important that they have those three things.
And then once you have identified the person,
how do you ask for one?
The script goes like this.
"Jim, I'm really interested in getting promoted this year.
I've had an amazing year
and I cannot show this organization anything else to prove my worthiness
or my readiness for this promotion,
but I am aware that somebody has to be behind closed doors
arguing on my behalf and pounding the table.
You know me, you know my work and you are aware of the client feedback,
and I hope that you will feel comfortable arguing on my behalf."
If Jim knows you
and you have any kind of a relationship,
there's a very high probability that he will answer yes,
and if he says yes,
he will endeavor to get it done for you.
But there's also a shot that Jim might say no,
and if he says no, in my opinion,
there's only three reasons that he would tell you no.
The first is he doesn't think that he has enough exposure to your work
to have real credibility behind closed doors
to be impactful and effective on your behalf.
The second reason he may tell you no
is that you think he has the juice to get it done,
but he knows that he does not have the power to do it
and he is not going to admit that in that conversation with you.
(Laughter)
And the third reason that he would tell you no,
he doesn't like you.
He doesn't like you.
(Laughter)
And that's something that could happen.
But even that will be valuable information for you
that will help to inform your next conversation with a sponsor
that might make it a little bit more impactful.
I cannot tell you how important it is to have a sponsor.
It is the critical relationship in your career.
A mentor, frankly, is a nice to have,
but you can survive a long time in your career without a mentor,
but you are not going to ascend in any organization without a sponsor.
It is so critical that you should ask yourself regularly,
"Who's carrying my paper into the room?
Who is carrying my paper into the room?"
And if you can't answer who is carrying your paper into the room,
then I will tell you to divert some of your hardworking energies
into investing in a sponsor relationship,
because it will be critical to your success.
And as I close, let me give a word
to the would-be sponsors that are in the room.
If you have been invited into the room,
know that you have a seat at that table,
and if you have a seat at the table,
you have a responsibility to speak.
Don't waste your power worrying about what people are going to say
and whether or not they think you might be supporting someone
just because they look like you.
If somebody is worthy of your currency,
spend it.
One thing I have learned after several decades on Wall Street
is the way to grow your power is to give it away,
and your voice is at the heart.
(Applause)
And your voice is at the heart of your power.
Use it.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)